[Music]
in preparing for this interview one of
the things that I learned about you is
that you make a point to eat lunch with
most of your employees at HSN
particularly for their 1st 5th 10th and
20th anniversary's and I've heard you're
known for sitting down and asking why
are you at HSN and what keeps you here
so Mindy to get us started would you
mind if I asked you why are you at HSN
and what keeps you there that's a great
question and to your point I learned
more from those breakfasts and those
lunches then you can buy reading any
report or doing anything you've got to
have the pulse of your company what
people are thinking what they're feeling
and I believe that culture Trump's
strategy and I know people have written
about that but I think that you can't
have a long term successful sustainable
company unless you have an incredibly
engaged culture and I've been fortunate
to work for many of those and it
certainly helped me in the
transformation of HSN but I think where
I want to start to kind of get to the
point of how I ended up making the
decision to go to HSN which at the time
was a pretty big risk according to many
people and I'm known as somewhat of an
unconventional risk-taker and it really
started Papa had she's just driving area
you know my my career and the fact that
I'm even in this business was definitely
not my original path so you know just
quick story I was I finished high school
at 16 and my junior year you know went
into college I was an English literature
and philosophy major and there I was in
my last semester at GW I was engaged to
be married to my high school sweetheart
who was going to become a doctor and I
was graduating and I was going to go to
law school so if any of you can relate
it's every stereotype of a Jewish mother
[Laughter]
and I was an adopted kid first one to
ever go to college so everything was in
the stars and I literally and I'm sure
you know I say that I woke up but I'm
sure it was on my mind but I did wake up
one morning and said I can't do this I'm
living someone else's life and I have to
live my life and with that I called my
folks and I said I have something to
tell you not getting married
I'm not going to law school and I'm
leaving school right now and I'm moving
to New York because I'm gonna figure it
out and that's what I did and I moved to
Manhattan in 1997 and said I know that I
want to be in a creative field I may not
be the creator and I don't know how I
said it in my head at the time but I
said I want to be in the business of
making creative people successful and
it's the first time that I realized that
you know having the power to do that was
it really gave me the feeling of if you
believe in yourself and you really to
the point that Jennifer made passion
purpose and impact you know and the
quote that you see up there risk-taking
and boldness is the essence of
transformation that moment that I picked
up the phone I made that decision
transform my entire life it did it
wasn't picking up the phone and going
I'm gonna be a CEO of a public company
it was picking up the phone and going
I'm gonna do what I'm passionate about
and I'm going to be able to take chances
and so throughout the course of my
career I think people now have made it
you know kind of a joke okay what is she
going to do next because it's going to
be something different but you know it
was you know leaving Tommy Hilfiger to
go run chops Ralph Lauren when that was
the hottest company but I knew that
they're gonna be very few opportunities
for a woman president and the menswear
industry or deciding to leave a company
when I didn't feel the values of the CEO
of that company lined up with me and I
quit without having another job which
made Ralph Lauren come and hire me
because I've been running another
business it was making a decision to
start up polo jeans it was making the
decision to leave polo jeans and go to
which was also very unconventional
because I was one of the first outsiders
to really come into the company
especially you know the fashion doyon
from New York and then fast forward to
how I made the decision to go to HSN you
know I'd been at Nike for six years and
it was a spectacular experience I
worship at the altar of Phil Knight he's
an amazing man
and I had great opportunities at that
company I was the most senior woman in
the organization I ran their global
apparel business but I also had the
opportunity to spearhead kind of their
transformation to really be more
emotionally connected to women some of
the work on the Nike Foundation and the
girl effect but I was at a pivotal point
in my career I was in my late 40s and
they had just announced a new CEO a new
president both of whom are about 50 and
had been at the company a long time and
most importantly they were in very good
health so that succession plan wasn't
looking like it was happening so fast it
was truly like you know what was life
after Nike gonna be look where was I
gonna go and I think you know too many
people were like she's gonna go run the
gap or she's gonna go run this and I
just knew that wasn't the case and I had
the opportunity to travel the world and
really see how technology was changing
the landscape much more so yet than it
had in the United States so really the
explosion of mobile in Japan and what
was happening you know around all the
marketing efforts whether it be the
Olympics or World Cup and I just said if
I'm gonna do anything I want to be in a
direct-to-consumer business because I'd
worked with all these great storytelling
brands and we would create the narrative
around the product and we would create
the technology for example at Nike and
we'd have all these stories and then I
would see my dreams dashed by going on
to a selling floor and nobody was
telling the story the right way to the
customer so I said I want to direct a
consumer business I want a business
that's going to be able to take
advantage of what's happening in
technology and what's happening in
changes in consumer behavior because the
way consumers were consuming right media
information how people were changing
their habits of shopping
could I take advantage of that and so
when I got this call from Barry Diller
to say I got a call from a recruiter
that Barry Diller wants to talk to you
about going to take over IAC retail and
I said that's great but what the hell
was i AC retail I never even heard of it
and they said well it's you know HSN in
this portfolio of these catalog and
e-commerce brands some of those I had
heard and I said well you know not
really sure but you wouldn't want to
have lunch with Barry Diller but if I'm
gonna have lunch with him I better have
a point of view so give me two weeks
let me do all my due diligence so let me
see if this is something really
interesting so I completely immersed
myself in the business and the the brand
and the competition and the marketplace
and I'll never forget I was watching and
I'm glued and I wasn't even familiar
with the before I'm glued to this
channel
you know like constantly and my
husband's like oh my god are we watching
this again and I also was a big Food
Network freak right al of Food Network's
this is eight years ago and I'm going
going what would I do with this what
would I do with this how could I make it
more engaging and interesting and all of
a sudden I was watching Food Network and
I clicked over to HSN and Wolfgang Puck
who was the only person in this video
that was on HSN at that time eight years
ago none of those other people had been
launched and the light bulb went off and
I said we have to stop thinking of this
as a selling channel and we have to
start thinking of as a network that's
going to inspire people to want things I
started getting really excited well we
could be like HGTV and Food Network and
style and DIY and we can transport
people through experiences and that's
when I had lunch with Barry and I said
okay here's the big idea if you're
willing to buy into this idea I'm
willing to take this plunge and do this
and if you're not it's not really
interesting and in great Barry fashion
because he epitomizes that he said go
forth now little did I know yes I was
the 8th CEO in 10 years the business has
stalled it was broken but you know I
think that sometimes the biggest
challenges actually transport
the greatest places so you decided to
join HS and a CEO in the first 90 days
what was your top priority when you
walked into the business so you know I I
knew that when you have eight CEOs in
ten years that's so disruptive to any
culture and what happens is the culture
freezes I always used the expression
it's like Miss Havisham and great
expectations you know there's cobwebs
because people are just waiting for the
next person to go so no strategy has
been implemented the business wasn't
performing so people were really feeling
downtrodden what were their
opportunities going to be for success
they were a trailing number two against
the competition and so you know I knew
that I was gonna have to make people
feel that something was very very
different so my head of HR actually
called me and said and I had not visited
the campus before I took the job because
they were making all these changes
before I came in and she said well how
do you want me to arrange her first day
and I said let me ask you a question
what is any other employee doing there
first day and she said well they go to
employee orientation I said well I'm
gonna go to employee orientation and she
said really I said absolutely because
it's gonna give me an insight and I
think it's gonna make people feel that
it is different so there I am my first
day I go into this room and there's like
25 people and everybody goes around the
table and introduces themselves and
somebody goes well I'm a merchandising
assistant I'm in backstage television
I'm in call sir and they get to me I say
I'm the new CEO and you could see well
that whole day I went to orientation I
was in the call center I was in
backstage television I was going through
creative I was understanding the shows I
actually answered calls well what
happened
it went viral it went viral throughout
the entire organization so by the next
day when I got up and did my first
townhall a it humanize me be it gave me
context of how to articulate what it was
we needed to do
and it made people feel that I was going
to be accessible and authentic and so
when I got up the next morning and I I
said here's why I joined the company and
we were talking earlier about
storytelling I knew the first story I
had to tell was why was I there why was
I passionate about the future of this
company and I had to make it personal
but because I'd had that experience I
was able to make it personal
so all of a sudden people felt that it
is different we do have a future and
we're gonna we're gonna go with her you
know on this path and I think that
really igniting the culture and being
believable and then setting a vision is
what changed the entire business dynamic
you you talked a lot about the
importance of culture and resetting the
culture at HSN a lot of leaders talk
about the importance of culture I'm
wondering if you can pull back the
curtain a bit for us and tactically
apart from town halls and telling your
personal narrative how did you build the
culture at HSN to what it is today so
the way I think about culture is I've
6,000 employees every one of them go
home at night every one of them has
neighbors
everyone goes visit and somebody or they
meet a new person and somebody goes who
do you work for you want that person to
be your greatest evangelist you want
them to be proud of what they're doing
and they're embedding themselves in the
culture and very often when people come
to visit of HSN they say oh my god it's
almost like a cult I think that's a good
thing by the way in a good way not a bad
way so it's Nike sews Ralph so you know
what I had to do was make employee
engagement the number one priority of
the company as while I was working on
the brand and the business strategy so
with my executive leadership team I said
we're gonna make an employee engagement
or number one strategy the second thing
I did was I was made it very clear to
the organization what my expectations
were and there were three sort of people
there were the evangelists that were
like woohoo we finally have someone here
who's gonna like take us somewhere the
second group of people were like sounds
interesting but let's see
you know they needed to give it time to
you know get through the period and then
the third group of people were the
blockers they were the toxins right I
believe that you have to get rid of
toxicity in any company that you have I
don't care how smart I don't care how
talented I don't care how they long
they've been there if somebody is going
to create a toxic environment you have
to make a change but they made it very
clear to people here are my expectations
I think the other thing that's important
I think too many CEOs who go into
companies that are not performing make
the incorrect assumption that everyone
in the company is probably not talented
it's usually because the leadership was
not inspired and it wasn't great
leadership so what I had to do was do a
talent assessment and I had a lot of
talented people that were actually
keeping the company together throughout
this time so I have the same my CFO
who's now CFO and CEO Jo smelling has
been there for 19 years she's been my
partner throughout this whole thing I've
had the same head of HR I've had the
same operational people but I did have
to bring new people in to the front of
the business who were going to have to
understand what a lifestyle brand was
and understand kind of what we were
trying to accomplish try to bring in a
new head of television I had to bring in
a new head of creative to make the
company become a digital company etc but
the number one thing I had to do was
inspire people around a vision and I
think when I'm always asked about water
qualities of leadership that ability to
set that vision and bring people along
with you and inspire them to get there
is critical so what I did six months
after I was there I set a giant tent up
we have a 70 acre campus in Florida so
we have seven television studios and
it's huge and so I erected this giant
tent and I had 2,500 people and then I
broadcast it to our other facilities
outside of Florida and we did a
multimedia presentation and we rolled
out the new vision the mission the
strategy we wrote a manifesto to our
customer and we basically told the story
of what our brand was going to be in the
future and how we were going to get
there
and at the time when we showed a video
at that event we had none of these
personalities so we had to use other
people's creative to get us there but
that was what launched all our new
creative our mission which was to bring
the joy and excitement of new
discoveries every day to our customer
and our vision for being a disruptive
force and changing the landscape of
retail and they were very bold
statements at the time considering where
the business was but if you know I think
too many people marginalize things you
know my husband used an economist and a
physicist physicist uses this expression
too many people are guilty of
infinitesimal incremental ISM right you
do have to set bold goals but then you
have to give people the path to get them
you just can't put them out there
without the strategy so I think it was a
combination of making everybody feel
they didn't have a job they had a
mission and if they embrace that mission
and became even Jellicle in a way that
we were going to create something that
didn't exist and we were going to change
the face of the business and that's what
excites people to this day when I have
those lunches and I go why are you here
and why do you stay the people the
culture and that we are connected to our
customer we're doing something different
every day the company has an
intellectual curiosity and we're
innovating and we want to be a company
of firsts that's what they say this past
year you've had a pretty big innovation
in your brand
so you've reconsent - it's fun here tell
us we know that brand is a lot more than
a tagline how do you reinvent a brand
yeah you know it's interesting I think
that there are different iterations you
kind of go through so when I first came
into the company it truly was
transformation I literally had to change
the way everyone employees the
marketplace are
customer when we went public the
shareholders how they thought of us as a
company that we were a Content company
versus a selling or a shopping company
that you know we were an innovation
company all of those things so that was
transformational and we built on the
brand strategy and the business strategy
well we're that a year year and a half
ago we were like okay we now need to
unlock that next level of growth and
we're going to have to be a little
disruptive and I'm a big believer if you
do not disrupt yourself you're going to
be disrupted by somebody else and I said
we need to disrupt our business a little
we have to reorganize how we're
structured we have to redeploy assets
against the things that are gonna be
more important it's not just watching a
live show on TV we're gonna have to
change how we create content for digital
and how we think of ourselves we're
going to have to change how we innovate
and we're going to have to look for
strategic partners and how we're going
to get there and we're going to have to
make some massive bets on capital
expenditures around systems and supply
chain etc but on the brand side what I
said was you know we we've we've
articulated there's no place like but
now we have to answer the question why
hmm now we have to tell her why we've
told her this is unique now we have to
tell her why and so we we did a lot of
consumer work we met with a lot of our
customers we under you know we do all
the time
we worked with two different companies
we work with an insights company and
then we worked with Deutsche to both say
what are the things that she's feeling
but what are the things that we have to
do to be able to bring a new generation
of customers in without alienating our
core customer how are we going to
surprise and delight so we took all that
work and we just we came up with the
answer to that question is it's fun here
it's spontaneous you never know what's
gonna happen next as I said our store
changes every day at least once a day
one of our team is saying you can't make
this stuff up because you got to
remember it's
five 24 hours a day it's like Vegas
right you're there at two o'clock in the
morning we're pumping the oxygen and you
don't know what time and that's really
where it what we're about and you know
one of the things that had real meaning
to me and why I really believe in this
tagline you know everybody remembers
2008-2009 were pretty tenuous times and
we went public in August 2008 probably
one of the last IPOs that happened and
I'll never forget I spent the summer of
you know it seems like a good idea in
November 2007 by the way but Judy and I
spent the summer raising the bank
financing and raising the debt so
imagine two women going in to all these
financial institutions explaining to
them why they needed to invest in a
company at that time that was all about
shopping but we were determined and we
raised every penny and more and we did
go public our stock came out at about
$10 and in December 2008 it was a dollar
43 at our market cap was smaller than
our receivable balance and had nothing
to do with the fundamentals of the
business it had to do with the fact that
the world was falling apart
and I needed to keep the organization
forward moving forward it's probably one
of the toughest leadership times I ever
had because I knew I had the faith of
6,000 people and their families at stake
I also knew our strategy was working so
we really had to go out and focus on the
sell side but I also had to focus on my
customer because what I was feeling and
what my employees were feeling she was
feeling the world was falling apart
around her and I remember saying to our
organization she may not be able to buy
anything right now but there's never
gonna be any bad news on HSN we're not
gonna not acknowledge what's happening
but you know what instead of selling
high-end jewelry we're gonna tell her
how to save money and how to cook at
home for her family we're going to tell
her why this heater is gonna save her a
fuel bill or we're just gonna make her
feel great if she wants to buy a mascara
and we're gonna really respect her and
make her feel great if she can't buy
anything this is a place that she can
come and be a respite for the storm
because it is fun here and a lot of
people weren't having fun then
and I think that our approach both in
our employees and I out the second thing
about that time I think the companies
who have really not just survived but
have thrived post that period are the
companies that decided to take it as an
opportunity to be offensive and not
defensive and invest appropriately and
redeploy appropriately and galvanize
against something and I'm a big believer
that how we manage that period was a big
part of our success and is what our
customer responded to and she continues
to respond and that's why we measure not
just employee engagement but customer
engagement and that idea of giving her
experiences every single day are so
important and since you've weathered
that storm HSN has seen phenomenal
growth and one thing I'm curious about
is as a business leader how do you
balance initiating things to drive
revenue and spend per customer
with ensuring that you're keeping the
customers best interests in mind and
they're not spending beyond their means
so you can disagree with the premise and
I think if you get like if you get
really good at what you're doing let's
talk about trust right so you know Trust
is across all your constituencies right
so if you fast forward today we have a
three billion dollar market cap and a
stock price of 56 we're a public company
so you know my belief and is that the
best companies yes they have to execute
quarterly but you run your business for
the long term number one that's really
critical so you talk about trust your
employees have to have trust your
customers have to have trust your
shareholders have to have trust and it's
a combination of trust and respect and
I'm asked the question how can I was
asked the question earlier well you talk
about trust all the time but you're kind
of really selling something to someone
and my answer to that is yes because
we're hsn.com/hsn org and we have to
have revenue we have to have profits but
we have to do it the right way so
I have to have trust and respect for my
customers so when I got to the company
they were selling products that weren't
of the quality that they should be they
had moved 30 percent of our calls
offshore so she wasn't getting the
service and the respect when she called
in that she needed to be and we weren't
respecting her as an individual so we
completely changed the dynamic and said
we're going to invest and I'm willing to
lose profits in the short term to create
an experience that was going to retain
my customers in the long term so we
actually spent more even when we weren't
performing as a business we brought all
those calls back we created a work at
home program we added a thousand jobs in
our local communities we were in that
enabled us to get a higher level of
individual that works for us and that
program is now six years old and has
expanded and we've written a white paper
now other companies use it we now have
some of the highest not just employee
engagement scores but customer
engagement scores so that was one number
two we were varied we used a very strong
filter in the products the stories and
the storytellers we were going to have
and we made quality our number one
priority because we actually have to
excite the customer twice once when she
feels this is a product that she wants
and second when she gets at home and the
last thing we want to do is disappoint
someone we want her to get even more
excited the third thing that we did was
we eradicated the word selling in our
vernacular and we change it too we need
to inspire people to want to engage with
the product so if we're exciting her and
Ming Tsai is on the air and he is
creating an incredible demo and showing
you how you can cook your dinner more
quickly because you're going to have the
slow cooker and you think that's great
for your family our job is to give ideas
give information give education and
hopefully entertain so our customer can
make an informed decision
an important decision of what she can
afford an informed decision of is this
product right for her and an informed
decision so she can then communicate
that to other people we also made it
very clear that and we communicate that
if you watch any of our shows you can
return anything you can return anything
because if it doesn't make you happy if
it's not what you thought you wanted we
care more about you than anything else
that was a huge paradigm shift for our
company and I get letters from our
customers all the time and I think that
they feel like they're more family than
they are a customer and I think that's
really important making a family and
wondering if because switch gears a bit
and talk a bit about your personal life
who are the people in your life that
have inspired your sense of self and
confidence you know I have I'm fortunate
to have really had a few so it's
interesting my mom got married when she
was 18 she couldn't finish high school
because her mother got very sick my dad
was 22 when they got married and he
didn't he was in the Armed Services and
she tried for 1012 years couldn't have
children and finally when she was 30 my
dad worked nights in the produce
business and his boss who he worked for
gave my parents the money so they could
adopt me and so from the time I was like
little you know I always remember my mom
saying you were special you can do
anything you want and I felt part
responsibility you know I was kind of a
little serious you know I guess when I
was younger to prove I could you but
there was one thing my mother always
said to me that has stayed with me my
whole life and it probably annoyed me
sometimes at the time which it probably
does my daughter now but when something
would happen whether it was good or
whether it was bad if a boyfriend broke
up with me or something could happen and
I was complaining or I was excited she
said Mindy everything in life is be
shared means it's meant to be and what
it's made me do is I never look
backwards I only look forward because
it's like that movie sliding doors he
knows what could happen
that bad thing didn't happen you know
what what what else could have been
behind that door which is why I believe
I'm an optimist you know I've been
quoted as I only hire tickers I don't
hire yours
I'm not very good at negative energy but
it's that everything in life is meant to
be and I really embrace that so that's
probably from a personal perspective and
then I think from a business perspective
there's definitely been a few things
working for Ralph Lauren you really you
you you are at the altar of brand right
and I'll never forget when I was
launching you know a number of our
brands he used to come and walk through
the showroom and it would be like he
show up and he'd be like I'll be and he
would go up to something it could be a
fixture or it could be a you know shirt
and he go Mindy tell me why it's a Ralph
Lauren before I put the label on it
where did it come from what was it
inspired by what's the integrity behind
that product and why should it be part
of my brand second thing he taught me
was it's more important what you learn
to say no to in your brand because if
you make that one mistake you will
violate the trust of what that brand is
and there have been quite a number of
whether they be brands or celebrities or
personalities that have been an
opportunity to come to HSN and I
probably could have done a lot of
business but I knew they weren't right
for our brand I knew they weren't right
for our culture I knew they weren't the
right kind of people and sometimes you
have to let business go if it's not the
right thing for your brand and then you
know Phil Knight who is one of the most
inspirational amazing people on what he
believes in in terms of an inspiration
and innovation and culture and humanity
is so important but the one that one
thing I really remember I was having
this conversation with him and I must
have been frustrated that one of the
people on my team you know I'm like I
can't get them to you know evolve or you
know move up and and I was you know I
was trying to fix people right and he
said he finally said to me Mindy you
will be a lot more successful the
company will be a lot more successful
and you will be a lot less frustrated if
you stop trying to make ordinary people
extraordinary and surround yourself with
extraordinary people and I always
learned that you know there's an
extraordinary in everyone and it doesn't
matter how many degrees you have it
doesn't matter what your background is
it doesn't matter what your provenance
is you need to look for extraordinary
people with soul people who have the
humanistic characteristics as well as
the talent and then lastly working for
Barry even though it was only a couple
of years the psyche idea and I was
always a risk taker but really to
understand what that means in today's
environment that you know you've got to
be able to block out the external noise
and do what you think is is right even
if it goes against the grain I want to
make sure we leave some time for
questions from the audience but before
we do that you have done a lot of these
interviews and I have a lot of questions
we're not gonna have time to get to
today I'm curious when you are done with
an interview if you're ever left
thinking I wonder why they're not asking
me X what should we be asking you that
we're not asking you I have found that
there's a lot of smart young people who
really know what questions to ask
I I wish some of you were at some of our
investor conferences because you ask
much better questions you know you know
I think too many people you know ask the
business questions I think what we
talked to her about today it's really
important I think you you have to ask
the soul questions you know what drives
people what motivates people whether
it's an employee or a customer and you
know when I look at the leaders that I
respect and I go to all these
conferences what I want to hear is the
why I want to hear the why behind you
know when I go and meet with investors I
know that they're investing in the
company but they're also investing in me
and they're investing in my leadership
team and I actually ask them to ask the
tougher questions you know ask the
questions of you know what why do you
believe this not
the numbers not just the things what are
they telling you how do you look at your
competition why do you think you're
gonna be successful it's the whys it's
the whys and you have to keep digging
deeper you know particularly as you're
deciding you know what businesses you
want to want to be in and you know I
talked to people you know a lot and I'll
say you know what are you looking for
what are you looking for in a company
and I get the business side of it and
like no no what are you looking for in a
company that you think aligns with who
you are and what your values are and is
it a company poised for growth is it a
company poised for success and I think
too many people get entranced by big
they get in trance by size you got to
get in trance by opportunity and what
you think you can bring to the table and
that's why that conversation about
impact is so important to me because
what impact was when I was 20 and what I
could do and I tried to have impact and
I tried to make other people successful
that was my impact what I think of
impact today and creating value what I
think of impact today for me personally
in philanthropy is a very different
thing if I've been privileged to be able
to get to this point I have a
responsibility now to have impact beyond
myself so whether it's my work at UNICEF
or going into the field or HSN cares
those are the things that are the most
rewarding so again it goes back to the
why I have lots of questions I'd love to
ask you but I want to give you guys a
chance so we're gonna open it up for
about five minutes of questions for
Mindy and then we'll close it out up
here first question from the audience
via Twitter was Mindy when you first
arrived at HSN how did you identify the
people who you could trust and rely upon
for your transformation it's a great
question and it was the first thing I
needed to do as I said before I brought
my leadership team together as well as
articulated to the company what my
personal philosophy was what was
acceptable
behavior and the people and the
character that I was looking for and
what wasn't acceptable we very quickly
defined what the elements of our culture
were and what people had to do and the
type of people that were going to be
successful in that culture and then I
really had to put that through a filter
and determine who was not going to be
successful and determined who was and
make some hard decisions and there were
hard decisions there were some people
who I will tell you right now have gone
on you know to other companies but I
knew that they didn't fit the future and
they wouldn't fit with me and they
weren't going to be a positive you know
element of this transformation and they
were going to make it harder and you
know the the key was is to get in my
head I needed people who could inspire
people I needed people who understood
what the transition was to a lifestyle
brand I needed people that were going to
be evangelists and work to engage the
culture that had positivity that
certainly they had to have the brains
and the intellect and the capability but
it wasn't about a resume it was about
who those human beings are and more
important were they going to make it a
mission and what are they going to
commit and fortunately as I mentioned
before I had some very talented people
but what I really appreciate is the
first people I hired you know Bill brand
is now our CMO and had a business
development for the corporation auntie
Sheldon is now opening our entertainment
offices in LA so all the people that
came in in the beginning are still there
because they still think it's a mission
and I think that's really important
hi I'm Dorothy Walter maybe MBA one
thank you so much for coming in to speak
with us today I have a question about
how you view HSN's role in launching new
brands what are the success factors and
also risks and how do you wrap your head
around that thank you that's a great
question
I actually think of it as a privilege to
work with new brands and I think in
today's world a lot of brands Achatz
it's harder and harder to tell their
stories right
brands are distribution captive there
are less stores there are less vehicles
the places you can tell your story
they're very crowded so to be able to
help a new brand or a younger brand
being able to give voice to their story
is really exciting to me so I get as
excited about the entrepreneur who
created this product in her garage so
her kids could learn how to flip and
fold
as I am you know Keith Urban and his
guitar they're all rock stars so what we
do is spend a lot of time trying to
understand what the brand wants to
articulate and what the DNA of that
brand is and you know the way I look at
it I have a competitor two and a half
times my size so if it's just about how
many of these you could sell in the
first five minutes I'm not going to be
very compelling but if my value
proposition is that I'm going to be able
to tell your story and I'm going to win
invest in understanding your story and
I'm going to invest in articulating that
whether it's through asset whether it's
through an environment whether it's
through creative or whatever that is and
I'm going to bring your story to life
that to me is a relationship and we will
do everything possible to make that
successful now that is not to say that
everything works it doesn't I can do
anything for a brand but I can't
personally make the product sell if for
some reason it's not resonating with the
customer but we will do everything in
our power and we will never end a
relationship disrespectfully or abruptly
you know we will be very clear
throughout that process
and we've actually had some people that
we didn't have immediate success with
but the year later they'd honed their
business or their product or their brand
and we decided to relaunch them and have
success so where our teams do our teams
are scouring you know the world for
great products and great stories and
great brands we also have ideas and we
create them you know what we're doing
with Disney for example at the end of
this month
he saw oz the great and powerful so
where Disney's partner for Maleficent
which is launching going into theaters
at the end of March with Angelina Jolie
so we went out to 50 different brands
from small to big and we had people
create products inspired by the
inspiration of the story and we're
creating a 24-hour event on air so you
have a little entrepreneurial brand next
to you know a big brand but what they're
all doing is just creating inspiring
stories and that's what's exciting for
us is to be able to do that you're gonna
take it okay oh yeah one last question
no pressure um hi my name is Gillian
health I am an MBA - my question is
around how you see your role and your
objective as a CEO today and I'm
wondering how that's changed since you
took the role on initially so you know I
look at the CEO role as multiple levels
right I am responsible for making sure
I'm creating sustainable value for my
company which is going to ultimately
then create value for all the
constituencies we have whether it's our
customers our employees or our
shareholders but I'm also responsible
for being the Shepherd of my brands and
for my company and I'm also responsible
for creating sustainable opportunities
and success for people and I take all of
that very very seriously
and I say love that because sometimes to
your earlier point they can be
conflicting priorities there are times
where you know I have to make a decision
and I have not made the decision to make
money in that quarter because I'm not
going to make the wrong decision for the
long-term of the business but I'm very
clear about why I decided to do
something and my shareholders understand
because I've been consistent with our
strategy and our story for six years
I've never deviated so they trust the
decisions that I'm making even though it
might have a short-term disruption are
right for the long-term value of the
business which is why I think we have
long-term shareholders and great
institutions because that really is my
job is to understand the choices and to
make the right and educated choices for
the long-term success of the company
the second thing it's my job as a CEO to
really lead and be a role model for what
I do and what I say both internally and
externally and it's to set the an
example and I take that really seriously
because the worst thing that I could do
is sit up here and say we do all of this
and then all of a sudden I act
differently or I say something different
it's not real and it's not authentic so
I have to kind of live and walk the walk
and whether it be about you know why we
launched HSN cares or you know what we
have to invest in or if I do have to you
know consolidate a business and maybe I
do have to lay off some people because
if I don't I can't deploy the resources
that'll take the company forward but
anyone that knows me knows that if I do
that I'm going to do it respectfully and
people are going to understand the
reasons why so I look at that role in
very broad terms many most of us here
today are thinking about what to do next
now that schools wrapping up and
charting career paths of our own with
some uncertainty and this is a quote
that you said last year at in New York
and this is something that I know you
tell your daughter I'm wondering if you
could expand on it in closing for us as
MBAs and how you might encourage us to
leap into it I think it's really
important that people not be afraid of
risk now there is a big difference
between risk and suicide okay I just
want to be clear and what I mean by that
is don't only look at what's in front of
you today don't only look at what's out
there today find take the insights of
everything that you've learned take the
insights and intellectual curiosity you
have to look what's out there and say
what do I want to be part of what do I
want you know what do I want to get that
experience right what do I see as
growing what do I see is you know that
that next thing and it's kind of like
we're looking at a lot of acquisitions
right now and I'm looking for those
things that are going to have the big
growth opportunities right and you have
to decide what level of risks you're
going to take at any given point in your
career but the time when you can really
do it and have the different experiences
is early right I have a I have a number
of friends who I said to them you're
miserable right why are you still doing
this because they felt trapped never be
in a position to feel trapped believe in
yourself enough that you need to find
those things that are because if you're
inspired and you're excited and you're
part of something you're probably going
to be successful because you're doing
what you love and you know it's
interesting my husband went to school at
his undergraduate his master's and his
postgraduate in applied mathematics and
physics he's like a real geek he studied
with Steven Hawkins right and he goes I
don't think I want to do then he went to
law school
you know and then he went any practice
law for five years and he was miserable
and it's kind of when I met him and he
said you know what
I can't do this and he just decided to
give up law and made a Segway and said I
want to figure out maybe how to go into
banking which he did and he went and he
said I'm gonna make my segue from into
derivatives and swap documentation and
went into finance aback but but you know
he's always been one of these people
that you know it is true heart and so I
think he's an academic but he's got this
incredible intellectual curiosity and
the most important thing for him is I
need to fill my intellectual curiosity
so that was always his guiding post you
know mine was I've got to be inspired
and I have to be creative and I have to
have an outlet for my creativity the
most important thing you can do and the
most empowering thing you will ever do
throughout your entire life is know
yourself know yourself
I think self-awareness is the key to
everything we spend a lot of time on
that no no the good the bad and the ugly
right right around there okay trust me
you know I know what my derailers are
right but it's empowering if you know
what you're made of because then you can
put those things through the filter of
what's real and what's important and
when people work for you if you're
really honest and you're willing to tell
people what your strengths are and
you're willing to tell them what your
weaknesses are they're gonna trust you a
lot more because you're willing to share
that and we have a joke we all know what
our derailers are mine I'm not very
patient sometimes one of the other guys
is mr. Fisk so he'll try and you know
when when you're under stress you have
to know what it is so we can be in a
meeting and we'll be able to call each
other out and go up your derailer right
and I just think it's you know
self-awareness is empowering so know
everything you can about yourself know
what gets you excited and then find that
path Mindy thank you so much for being
here with us today we really appreciate
it and
[Music]